[Music]  get ready for a devilishly good time  after 500 years  Umbra witch Bayonetta was revived in the  present day in the first Bayonetta game  she clashed with angels to recover her  lost memories  and in the second confronted demons to  save her best friend  now in this third installment she'll  fight to protect the world from the  sudden invasion of man-made bio weapons  called homunculi  [Music]  she's gone from fighting for herself to  fighting for others to fighting for the  world  those who have overcome their past  histories with Bayonetta to fight  alongside her include the journalist  Luca  and another Umbra witch Jean  new ally Viola also joins in on the  action  a hair raising  demon summoning Globe trotting Adventure  awaits in Bayonetta 3 launching a  Nintendo switch October 28th pre-orders  are available now on Nintendo eShop  after today's Nintendo Direct a new  trailer delving more into gameplay will  launch on our official YouTube channel